Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be my full video for
Marvel's werewolf by night there's a whole
bunch of Easter eggs and references we'll break
it all down I'll also explain how he fits into
the larger MCU like how this is connected to all
the other movies Marvel phase five stuff that's
happening because it is Marvel's first time doing
this special presentation that they call it's sort
of like a one-off like a short movie or a really
long episode of Television instead of doing like
a traditional series with a bunch of episodes
or doing like a full two hour plus movie but
it is meant to be Marvel's first legit horror
project and their first Monster base project
like we have the blade movie with mahershala
ali coming up we'll start seeing more Monster
characters like this in the MCU if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos and careful for spoilers from the
special if you haven't seen it yet we'll start at
the beginning work our way through shot by shot
talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments as we
go along but the werewolf finite is Jack Russell
that's his name inside the MCU as a human he's
played by Gail Garcia Bernal amazingly I thought
he did a great job pretty much everybody in this
special knew the the assignment they kind of knew
the vibe and the tone that they were going for
Michael giacchino directed it and he did the music
for it he's traditionally known as the person who
does music for a lot of the big Marvel Disney
other related films his powers are basically a
normal werewolf's Powers I'll explain his origin
story too but the cool connection to Moon Knight
is that Moon Knight is a character originally
debuted in the werewolf By Night comic book the
main reason why he didn't appear for the first
time in the Moon Knight series is because they
were saving him for this particular special and
because the tone the feel of this was so different
from Moon Knight Moon Knight was much more of
a traditional Marvel Series this is meant to be
more of an homage to the classic Universal monster
movies like Werewolf of London the thing from the
Black Lagoon Dracula Frankenstein all the stuff
like that that's why it felt like they were doing
a 1930s movie as if it were happening in the 1930s
but with modern technology the obvious connection
to the larger MCU is stuff like the blade movie
more Supernatural characters teaming up eventually
this will kind of tease that during this episode
too like Elsa Bloodstone comes from this famous
family of hunters he comes from a family of
monsters but they find a way to work together
they imply that they will eventually team up more
in the future obviously another big introduction
during this series is the man thing character in
the MCU the funny thing is there was actually a
Man-Thing movie that was done in the pre MCU days
like before Marvel Studios really started making
its own projects we'll see if he comes back during
the blade movie I believe there'll be a connection
to the Kit Harington Black Knight character
like Black Knight vampire Hunter and that's
why blade showed up in his post-credits scene this
is also the path to them explaining how characters
like Ghost Rider can exist in this universe just
generally Supernatural monster-based characters
like you'd expect the special Marvel intro for
the Marvel presentation that they do that's in
color at the beginning of the episode I think
that they're just going to use before all the
other similar types of one-off specials that
they do and they did tease that they would do
more projects like this now obviously each one
would have its own separate tone so like some
of them will feel like more traditional Modern
Marvel films in the style of some of the other
ones might be a little bit weirder kind of like
this one a lot of this is also just having fun
trying experiments with different types of movies
and projects inside the MCU like even though they
all feel like very different types of projects
from different places they're all taking place
inside the MCU they have that really cool special
intro scene where they interrupt the traditional
Marvel Studios intro with the werewolf slashing
through the screen with his claws and changing
to black and white to set the whole tone for the
monster movie 1930s classic Vibe also the music
and the audio takes on a very 1930s quality
too like the singing that happens across the
Marvel credits once it goes to black and white
is done in the same style as it would have been
if it had happened in the 1930s but the stuff
that they're saying here when they're chanting
and seeing during this part of the intro is the
exact same thing that they're saying during the
traditional Marvel Studios intro another really
cool homage to classic film is The Wizard of Oz
Easter egg there are a couple in the episode
at the beginning when they change from color
to black and white and then at the end when they
change from black and white to color that happens
during The Wizard of Oz because it was one of
the very first color films that was released at
the time most of the films that have been released
were all black and white so color was like a brand
new thing so during that movie they wanted to ease
the transition for a lot of audiences around the
country that were seeing color films for the first
time they also Play Somewhere Over the Rainbow the
song from Wizard of Oz at the end of the episode
and you also noticed throughout the episode the
only color comes from the Bloodstone itself like
the ruby slippers in Wizard of Oz the whole thing
with the Bloodstone itself is that it's meant
to be a fragment of a mystery meteorite that
crashed to Earth in ancient times the same way the
vibranium meteorite crashed to Earth the lightning
cracking across the logo here is a reference
to the Frankenstein movie like I said another
classic Universal monster movie the opening
scene narration is meant to tell you where this
takes place when it takes place in the timeline
after Avengers end game like The Avengers already
exists when it mentions the known universe
that's a reference to the monsters and other
Supernatural characters we haven't seen a lot of
in the MCU until now so they reference things like
vampires before in the MCU and the Thor movies
but until recently we hadn't really seen any even
mahershala Ali's blade character that debuted
during the eternal's post-credits scene was off
screen like we didn't see him when the voiceover
is referencing The Avengers it calls them Marvels
for Marvel Comics Marvel Studios this is a Vampire
the cycles of the Moon next to it are reference to
werewolves also technically a reference to konshu
and Moon Knight which itself has a big link to the
werewolf finite character Moon Knight himself
didn't appear during the episode and supposedly
blade was also supposed to have a cameo but there
was some scheduling issue that kept him out of it
there were a couple references to Blade during
the special I'll talk about those when we get
to those part of the episode some of the monsters
weren't totally clear but they're all meant to be
canonical Marvel comic book monsters so if you are
a big fan of those monster Marvel comic books you
probably recognized a lot of these I think this
one is meant to be an Atlantean or connected to
Atlantis in the MCU which in the MCU is going
to be featured in Black Panther wakanda forever
but in the MCU they're changing the backstory
a little bit and they're calling it talocon and
it's a city underwater it in namor's character are
based more on Aztec and Mayan culture mythology
the Trident is meant to be another reference to
Namor who we'll also see during black panther
wakanda forever like I just did a trailer video
for that the man with the bow is an old-timey
Hawkeye reference but also the creature is a
werewolf and it's meant to be a reference to
the Ancient Hunters in Elsa bloodstone's family
like this ancient line of hunters the Hawaii is
that their family founded this order of hunters
dedicating to eradicating all types of monsters
in the MCU but I think the idea with Elsa is
that like Jack Russell they both only hunt the
bad monsters they spend a lot of time in the
episode with them together trying to humanize
monsters just in general so that you sympathize
more with them by the end this is a reference
to the ancient Bloodstone family using their
trademark Bloodstone gem to fight Bigfoot that's
right Bigfoot is Canon to the MCU now and his
head is mounted on the wall R.I.P Bigfoot in the
comics the Bloodstone basically has all the same
powers that they talk about during the episode
like it gives you a form of invincibility enhanced
strength speed protection regeneration telepathic
Powers it even extends your lifespan too which
they reference a lot when talking about her
father her father Ulysses Bloodstone lived for an
extremely long time because of it and that's why
he looks kind of like Frankenstein's monster at
the end of the episode because he's ancient also
because of the classic monster movie Vibe of the
entire special they are literally trying to make a
Frankenstein reference because he has stitches all
over his head I guess you could also make a Tales
from the Crypt crypt keeper reference because
he has this animatronic thing going on with his
corpse the reason this character looks kind of
like Conan though is because the Bloodstone comes
from the hiborian age Comics which is where the
Conan character comes from Marvel doesn't have the
rights to all the Conan stuff but for a long time
they did publish the Conan Comics this medieval
reference looks like a version of Camelot in the
MCU like the eternals movie canonized Camelot
King Arthur Excalibur Merlin and the MCU that
would have been around this same period in MCU
history the events of the episode basically cover
the death of Ulysses Bloodstone in the ceremony
that they hold to select the next wielder the
Bloodstone and leader of their family in the
comics the next wielder was his daughter Elsa and
that's basically the way things play out in the
episode like she winds up getting the Bloodstone
by the end and taking control of the family the
special Monster hunting contest that they hold
for the Bloodstone though is to find and kill
man thing like whoever finds him and takes the
Bloodstone from him also implied that they kill
man thing winds up winning the whole reason why
Jack Russell is here in the first place though is
because he's trying to save his friend Ted salus
which is why he calls man thing Ted that's his
original name when he was still human man thing is
sort of like Marvel's version of Swamp Thing but I
believe that he actually debuted before the Swamp
Thing comic book debuted so technically he came
first even though I think the Alan Moore developed
a concept of a swamp thing before a man thing it's
just that Marvel was able to get man thing out on
shelves before they got Swamp Thing out he has a
very super soldier type of backstory the whole
idea is that he was working as a scientist with
aim they were trying to recreate the super soldier
serum so he developed a special concoction and
wound up taking it and crashing into a mystical
Swap and that's how he got his powers transforming
into what you see here he looks pretty accurate
to the comics one of the big changes though from
Swamp thing is that he has a lot of multi-verse
bass powers like he has crazy Powers the whole
thing with him burning people is that he's
actually attracted to fear and he'll burn
anyone who is afraid of him which is why he keeps
telling Elsa when she approaches him to treat him
like an old friend and call him by name like hey
Ted that's a great name you seem pretty cool so
she doesn't get burned but everybody else who's
terrified of him gets burned he can fly he can
control plant life obviously he can also teleport
which they referenced during the episode too
like Jack Russell tells him oh the Bloodstone is
weakening your powers you can't escape on your own
otherwise he would just teleport on his own and
save himself it's also how they escape at the end
with the record player that's playing a version
of Somewhere Over the Rainbow because man thing
apparently just really liked it and teleported it
with them they also implied that werewolf by night
and man thing have been friends for a long time
having Adventures for a long time because they
have that funny argument at the end where they
joke about who saves the other one the most like
this type of thing has happened to them a lot
and also when he's talking to Elsa during the
episode he says that he's a hunter but not that
kind of Hunter which is just a reference to him
hunting all the bad monsters kind of in the way
that blade kills vampires but mostly just the bad
vampires is the problem is is that most vampires
are bad so that's why it seems like blade kills
all vampires and even though those are the pop
culture connection between werewolves and vampires
werewolf finite's backstory actually comes
from Dracula when he starts talking about his
complicated quote unquote family he's referencing
his origin story originally his grandfather was
fighting Dracula in one of the werewolves that
Dracula was keeping captive bit his grandfather
and then the curse was passed down through
his family line when he was younger most of
his family wound up dying so nobody was actually
able to teach him about being a werewolf so when
he reached the age of maturity and transformed for
the first time he had no idea what was going on
but eventually he chose to use his powers for good
the murals on the walls when he walks in for the
first time tell the history of the Bloodstone
family fighting monsters across history since
ancient times this guy actually looks just like
the comic book version of Gore the god butcher
with the head Tails this is meant to be a werewolf
foreshadowing Jack Russell transforming into his
werewolf form the main room here is filled with
all kinds of Easter eggs for Marvel comic book
monsters if you think you recognize some of these
ones in the background let me know in the comments
what you think they are I think that most of them
are meant to be references to specific Marvel
Monsters the guards working here look just like
TVA agents but they might just be reusing some of
the TVA props the painting next to the casket is
of a young Ulysses Bloodstone with the Bloodstone
embedded in his chest which is meant to be sort of
an homage to the comic book art that's basically
how the Bloodstone works in the comics that's
why in the end credits you see Elsa with the
Bloodstone looking like it's in her chest now the
woman here playing his widow is Elsa's stepmother
they don't really explain what happened to her
biological mother but the way they talk about
her it sounds like she died under mysterious
circumstances maybe they'll get into that in
a future project because it sounds like Elsa is
going to come back just like werewolf is coming
back the Stepmother's name is verusa Bloodstone
I don't think she's from the comics I think they
just created her for the special here but she's
basically meant to be the main villain of this
series and I believe all the the hunters that they
have here too like the other side characters are
brand new to the episode I couldn't find any
specific comic book references to them when he
claims he fought the vampire on the wall here a
few times I don't think this is directly meant to
be Dracula I think he's just like another major
vampire lord from the comics there was a rumor
that Dracula was going to be the main villain in
the MCU blade movie with mahershal Ali but I think
that they've actually decided to completely change
the plot of that film and they're just rewriting
the whole script Dracula is an MCU character you
see him in all the moon night memes Dracula better
have my money this out of the whole contest with
man thing in the Bloodstone I've already explained
his backstory his connection to werewolf by night
in the MCU it also sounds like man thing will come
back in Future projects too like he's just a cool
dude who shows up and teleports you away and helps
you out when you need him I believe the skulls
that they use here at the beginning of the contest
is meant to be a vampire skull and obviously
the first time Jack Russell meets Elsa in the
Maze here they want to foreshadow them eventually
working together like okay you help me I'll help
you but then it turns into something bigger like
she starts to sympathize with him and the other
monsters the good monsters when she's fighting
this other Hunter this actually looks kind of like
a Black Widow leg move there's a lot of really
quick blink and you'll miss it references to Old
School films too like you'll see blood splatter on
the frame or you'll see the cigarette Burns where
they're changing reels as if they were changing
reels even though all Marvel's modern projects are
filmed digitally not on actual film they made it
look like it was on actual film this is just meant
to be their family's tomb they have bodies going
back centuries obviously the Bloodstone gives them
extended lifespans that's why some of the dates
seem kind of weird like her aunt died in 1922 like
wow that seems like a long time ago some of the
names though on the gravestones are names of real
life Marvel crew members working on the movies in
the Disney plus series when he says he understands
what it's like to grow up in a complicated family
that's a reference to his origin story in the way
that he found out that he was a werewolf and
obviously her backstory with her family of
hunters when she makes the joke about her aunt
being convinced that she was going to come back
from the dead that's a Marvel Zombies reference
but they also explored that Concept in Moon Knight
another werewolf By Night connection obviously
when they clarified how the MCU afterlife worked
you can actually come back from the dead the
afterlife is just a series of alternate Dimensions
that your Consciousness goes to depending on your
belief system or whether or not you form contracts
with higher level beings also in the end credits
you actually see a scene of her hand breaking out
of her tomb so it's like them paying off that
reference like oh she actually did come back to
life when he tries to reach for the Bloodstone it
winds up hurting him because he is a monster it
hurts all monsters not just werewolves then when
they're trapped in the cage together he implies
he still doesn't have total control over himself
when he's in werewolf form kind of like the Hulk
was before he learned to merge his two halves
into the professor Banner form so I think that
also might wind up happening to his character in
the future like he'll find a way to retain his
intelligence when he's in werewolf form when he
starts smelling her trying to remember her when
he changes form and he says that it's worked once
before that's a reference to the comic books when
he made a promise to his mother about not killing
his stepfather who he was able to remember in
werewolf form I really love the way they filmed
the reveal scene too just like the film technique
of them actually filming him transforming and
showing his face full-on for the first time also
when he's ripping all these people to shreds
they Splash Blood on the screen like you would
see in an old timey horror movie I think this
is actually the bloodiest thing that Marvel has
done so far if you don't count the original Blade
movies which were technically not MCU movies like
that was pretty Marvel Studios days before they
started making their own movies you also notice
Elsa uses Jack Russell's advice about dealing with
man thing treating him as a friend when she tries
to approach him in werewolf form which winds up
working like he winds up remembering her Deus
ex-man thing winds up showing up to hilariously
kill her stepmother because she was afraid of him
remember it's mostly a fear-based thing and I love
this joke between the two of them after the fact
too like he just asked where Jack Russell went
and she points him on his way like it's no big
deal like oh thanks so much for killing my awful
stepmother she takes over her family's house and
if it wasn't clear she's going to continue being
a hunter it's just that she's only going to be
hunting bad monsters like Jack Russell using his
powers for good they reference Wizard of Oz again
when it changes from color to black and white and
start using the song Somewhere Over the Rainbow
also the song itself like the lyrics of the song
are a reference to both of them kind of longing
for a better place like Somewhere Over the Rainbow
where things aren't quite so crazy like this and
they reveal that man thing teleported both of
them to safety the reason why they have that same
record player from earlier means that man thinks
stole it from The Maze just because he liked
it and they joke just chilling out like a couple
old friends like two dudes who do stuff like this
all the time a werewolf and a giant multiversal
teleporting swamp creature having coffee together
and going to get sushi they joke about who saves
each other more implying that they do this all
the time you also notice that they teleported an
old school pay telephone and a guitar I think the
joke here is the telephone was just something
that Jack Russell was holding when man thing
teleported him like it got teleported with him on
accident the reason why he doesn't want to think
about eating food at the moment is because he
literally just got done eating a bunch of humans
also Sushi is raw fish he just got done eating
a bunch of raw humans during the end credits
the red light is meant to be a reference to the
Bloodstone the other artifacts from the episode
they depict different scenes from the episode also
paying off a couple references too like there's a
depiction of Elsa's Aunt actually coming back
to life breaking out of her grave the heads on
the Pikes are just meant to be monsters from their
previous kills and also comic book Marvel monsters
if you think you recognize which ones there are
referenced to post it in the comments below you
also see the Bloodstone in Elsa's chest like her
father's which is basically how it works in the
comics overall it was a great special I love the
way they played this I love that they're doing
more horror stuff in the MCU what will probably
happen though is that when they bring werewolf
by night and Elsa back in Future crossovers with
darker Supernatural characters is it the tone the
vibe will be very different more like traditional
Marvel series maybe they'll come back during the
blade movie we'll see remember this is only
a one-off so like there's no episode two or
anything like that but if you spotted any other
Easter eggs and references in the episode that
I didn't talk about in the video just write them
Below in the comments everyone click here for my
Deadpool three Wolverine trailer video and
click here for my house the Dragon episode
8 video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!